c'est un pays déchiré par la guerre
civile qui s'apprête à se rendre aux
urnes
la république centrafricaine votent ce
dimanche pour élire son président et ses
140 députés un double scrutin à hauts
risques dans cet état d'afrique centrale
contrôlé en majeure partie par des
groupes armés il mène depuis une semaine
des combats dans certaines villes du
pays pour déstabiliser l'élection
pourtant mercredi signe encourageant
deux des principales factions rebelles
avaient décrété un cessez le feu de
trois jours une trêve finalement rompu
un jour avant la date butoir
face à l'entêtement irresponsable du
gouvernement de rejeter le cessez le feu
la coalition des patriotes pour le
changement décide de rompre la trêve de
72 heures qu'elle s'était jusque-là
imposé et de reprendre sa marche
implacable jusqu'à son objectif final
désormais soit le gouvernement nous
disperse soit nous marchons sur bangui
malgré la menace d'une offensive sur la
capitale par les rebelles
le président sortant et favori à sa
réélection faustin archange touadéra
exclut tout report du vote soutenu par
la communauté internationale
il aura à sa disposition 300 casques
bleus rwandais en renfort des soldats de
la minustah la mission de l'onu de
stabilisation en centrafrique un soutien
présent jusqu'à la fin du processus
électoral censé anticiper tout potentiel
conflit
la russie a de son côté envoyé 300
instructeurs militaires pour aider la
centrafrique à renforcer ses capacités
défensives selon moscou soutient enfin
de la france emmanuel macron a condamné
les tentatives de déstabilisation dans
le pays à la fois par les groupes armés
et par certains candidats de
l'opposition